Hello everybody, welcome back to "Here's an Idea",...
...a minute and a half or so of marketing insight.
I'm Hal Brice.
Today, I wanna share one of the coolest marketing things I've seen in quite a while.
This is a case study from Tesco out of Korea.
Now, Tesco is that big global retailer based in England...
...but they actually operate all around the world.
Their stores in Korea however, were struggling...
...because their main competitor out - stored them by a large margin...
...and they couldn't build stores fast enough to catch up.
So they ask themselves the question:...
...how can we become number one without having to build stores?
And their answer was to create virtual stores.
Take a look at this.
What they did was that they put in these Korean subways these virtual stores that were basically flat billboards.
And it looked like a grocery store.
While they're waiting for their train to come in,...
...customers walk up to the store...
...and punch a picture of the product they want with their QR code that's on each product.
That goes into their shopping cart on their phone which then is in turn sent to Tesco.
And by the time they get home from work,...
...right behind them comes the guy from Tesco with their products.
It really takes a lot of stress out of shopping,...
...and it allows them to take time which would be normally dead time,...
...and actually turn it into productive time.
So, that's just a sample of where the world of smartphones and things like QR codes are going,...
...taking a lot of the hassle out of shopping.
So, if you are a retailer, the question for you is...
...do you have a mobile strategy?
If not, it's time to get one.
That's "Here's an Idea."
Thanks for watching.
I'm Hal Brice.